تريستان هاريس هو أحد المطلعين على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي والمؤسس المشارك ورئيس
مركز التكنولوجيا الإنسانية الذي لعب دور البطولة فيه
في هذا الفيلم على Netflix والذي أطلق عليه اسم
المعضلة الاجتماعية التي كنت أرغب في التحدث
إليه لفترة من الوقت حول حروب الانتباه
داخل التكنولوجيا الكبيرة  سألته
ما هو أكثر أنواع
مستخدمي وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي قيمة ، فقال إنه ليس شخصًا
يعيش حياته بسعادة ، يرجى
مشاهدة ما قاله
لا ، إنه أكثر قيمة عندما يكون
مدمنًا على الاستقطاب الغاضب
النرجسي المضلل ويهتم
باهتمام الآخرين و  عرضة
للمعلومات المضللة لأن كل تلك
الصفات المدمنين الاستقطاب
النرجسي المشتت والمضلل هي
حالات نجاح لنموذج العمل ما هو
نموذج العمل كم دفعت
لك مقابل حساب Facebook الخاص بك في
العام
الماضي لا شيء جيد كيف يستحقون
أكثر  تريليون دولار يعتقد الناس
أنها البيانات وليست البيانات التي
يجب عليهم أن يوضحوا لك كيفية
عرضها  إذا كنت تعلن عن أنها يجب أن
تلفت انتباهك وهذا هو المكان الذي تعرفه
في عملنا ، يعرف الناس هذا من خلال
معضلة اجتماعية أن هذه الشركات
في سباق من أجل هذا النوع من الإمداد المحدود
من الاهتمام البشري ونحن نفد
، ولذا يجب عليهم أن يفعلوا ذلك  ندخل في
جوانب أكثر عدوانية مثل الجوانب
العاطفية لأذهاننا لجذب هذا الانتباه
تمامًا كما نفد النفط ،
وعلينا أن نبدأ في التكسير للنفط عندما
ينفد انتباهنا ، يتعين على الشركات
التعمق في النرجسية كمثال
على  هذا أنت تعرف أه هذه الشركات
للأطفال في سباق تسلح لمن
يمكنه تجميل الصورة التي
تعود إليك في المرآة هذه فلاتر الجمال هذه أم آه ،
لذا فإن سناب شات يظهر
لك مرآة على الحائط من
أجملها جميعًا  لديهم
حافز لإمتلاء
وجنتيك بشفتيك ممتلئة بعيونك حتى يكون لديك
صورة شخصية أجمل ولديهم سباق تسلح ،
لذلك دعنا نقول إن إنستغرام يدرك أن
هذا أمر سيء للصحة العقلية للأطفال.
لا يمكنهم التوقف عن ذلك ما لم
تتوقف الشركات الأخرى أيضًا ،
ووجدنا مؤخرًا أن tiktok يقوم بالفعل
بتجميل الصور دون أن نسأل
المستخدمين عنها حتى أنهم قاموا بتجميلها بنسبة
2 أو 3 في المائة فقط بشكل غير مرئي
وهذا هو نوع سباق التسلح الذي  كان